peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
depuis l'année 1974 quinze mille camions
soit quarante mille français s'adonnent
au camping car un nomadisme structure
est un moyen terme entre le chez soi et
l'hôtel venant des états unis cette
nouvelle vague de campeurs en
autocaravane traduisez campine cas
commencent à envahir nos routes
12 constructeurs viennent de voir le
jour en six mois et vendre leurs maisons
ambulantes entre 50000 et 150 mille
francs
un farouche adepte de ce genre de
loisirs patrick savoie vient d'écrire un
livre un livre contenant une somme
incroyable d'information sur la
réglementation l'acquisition les
conseils les formalités à remplir les
renseignements utiles
enfin sur tout ce qui concerne camping
car le camping cars permet une évasion
beaucoup plus autonome
c'est un moyen de tourisme très
indépendant qui au contraire des
caravanes évite le stationnement dans
les camps effectivement avec un
camping-car vous pouvez stationner ou
vous voulez dans les rues sur des places
sur une plage sommet du montagne vous
stationnez absolument où vous voulez moi
j'appellerai ça plutôt un mode de vie
une façon de voir
la vie sous un autre angle c'est à dire
une façon de s'évader des villes d'une
vie
très très très très envahissant très
structuré le camping-car n'exige que le
permis tourisme au contraire détracteurs
de caravanes donc ne pas dépasser pour
l'instant trois tonnes 5
quant aux mères de famille il était
légitime de leur demander leur avis sur
cette nouvelle forme de loisir c'est
beaucoup plus exigus on a beaucoup moins
de ménages à faire puis pour les reports
dans se contente d'être un petit pic
tech 1 légumes en face c'est plus facile
nous n'avons que par exemple moins de
vacances et nous allons très loin avec
beaucoup plus de facilité de liberté
nous faisant huit à dix mille kilomètres
pour pendant ce mois là eh bien je ne
pourrai pas le faire avec une petite
voiture ou est-ce que vous allez avec le
camping car vous allez de l'eau marron
oui salle non avec quelques j'ai déjà
fait 16 pays
lorsqu on peut stationner n'importe où
pourquoi ne pas prendre sa douche en
plein paris
[Musique]